excess deaths for people over 65 reached
the highest level since records began
during this Summer's heat waves a joint
report by the UK Health Security Agency
and the office for National statistics
shows the effect of this Summer's record
temperatures on excess mortality well
Skies correspondent Matthew Thompson has
all the details for us now a morning to
you Matthew what was the size of this
effect from the heat wave well fairly
substantial I mean we've known for some
time that heat waves can be deadly
particularly for the elderly but these
figures really illustrate quite how
deadly they can be and there's actually
two sets of figures out today from the
UK HSA and the ons and I'll take them
each by turn the first is specifically
by the UK HSA health Security Agency and
it looked at excess deaths in each of
the specific five Heat Wave periods over
the summer in England amongst the
elderly and they make for some fairly
Grim reading so across all five heat
waves from June to August there were
2803 excess deaths among the over 65s
that's defined as deaths above the
average levels just before and after the
heat wave struck and it's actually the
highest figure since records began in
2004 and during the hottest period which
was the 17th to the 20th of July that's
when temperatures you'll remember hit 40
degrees there were
1012 excess deaths among the over 65s
but the most deadly period was from the
8th to the 17th of August it was less
hot then but it was longer lasting and
that saw
1458 excess deaths in those over 65. and
then we have the ons data which looks
more broadly at the time period from
June to August and it showed that there
are 3
271 excess deaths for all age groups now
that's clearly a higher number than the
UK HSA figure but as I say it includes
all age groups and unlike the other data
it doesn't exclude deaths from covert
during that period so perhaps the UK HSA
figure is a more accurate reading of the
impact of the heat at least on elderly
deaths but either way it's fairly clear
that heat can kill and that Britain is
perhaps uniquely ill-equipped to deal
with the kinds of temperatures that we
may have to get used to in the years
ahead and that's going to require fairly
urgent action from the government on
things like retrofitting houses ensuring
there are shutters better ventilation
more green spaces and urban environments
for example to ensure that excess death
like these don't become more commonplace
in the years ahead